كيف كانت الاجواء لديك لحظه الافتتاح كيف
كان تفاعل الحشود من المتابعين والمشجعين
بعدين
مقصد المشجعين منذ ايام
توافدت بشكل كبير جدا منذ صباح هنا في هنا
في قلب الدوحه انا لن اطيل الكلام كثيرا
باعتبار باعتبار ان قطر الان بدات
مباراتها ملك ودور الى جانبي همم مشجعين
قطريين سنحاول رزقه همم
توقعاتهم بخصوص هذه المباراه
وامكانيه تحقيق قطر اليوم نتيجه برايك قد
تكون في صالح المنتخب القطري
بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله انا ان شاء الله اتوقع ان قطر
وتفوز اثنين واحد على الكوادر
هل تتوقع ان يكون المنتخب يحقق المنتخب
القطري انجاز في اول مشاركه نفسي
قطر النتيجه
طبعا الجماهير العربيه حاضره بقوه هنا في
في سوق واقف
ورايناها تجوب شوارع
السوق على امتداده بين الجماهير المغربيه
ومعنى مشجع مغربي كيف شفت اليوم انطلاق
المونديال وكثر توقعاتك لمباراه قطر
بدا مشاركه المنتخب المغربي
المنتخب القطري يعني
همم عنده مستوى عالي يعني مش راح يكون
يعني بالنسبه للمنتخب الثاني
[تصفيق]
موجود 35
000 تونس الحمد لله هذا اول كاس عالم في
دوله عربيه شرفتنا ونورتنا رؤوسنا
الحمد لله واليوم ان شاء الله قطر اليوم
ان شاء الله يا رب وان شاء الله العربي
فلسطين فلسطين وان شاء الله يا رب اربع
منتخبات عربيه المروك
والسعوديه والسعوديه وتونس
الجزائر
[تصفيق]
الايمان اليكم الخط شكرا
ايناس